[Applause]
hello everybody my name is Lisa parks
I'm a professor in comparative Media
Studies here at MIT and I'm really
delighted to be here it's one of the
first events I've really done here at
MIT and I'm so thrilled to be here with
Trevor and I want to thank all the
organizers and staff especially Trevor
and I first met at the transmedia
festival in Berlin about ten years ago
and at that time we both shared an
interest in satellites I put up the
slide of this book because Trevor
contributed to it generously and at that
time Trevor was trying to photograph
satellites from the surface of the earth
and I was trying to study them in terms
of their cultural implications we shared
an interest not only in satellites but
in other things such as
telecommunication infrastructure the
electromagnetic spectrum and you know at
one point I ended up being kind of his
Sherpa and walking up a mountain with
him for a couple of days while he was
shooting in the Nevada desert shooting
this area one shot at Groom Lake and at
that time it was really fascinating
because I got a sense of the invisible
labor that his work required when he was
lugging cameras around to different
sites to shoot secret government
installations throughout the the western
part of the u.s. we're going to spend
most of our time this half hour talking
about Trevor's machine vision works but
before we get into that I thought I
would just take a few minutes to talk
about some of my own research and to lay
out some some things that might we might
return to a discussion I'm a media
scholar and some of my recent work has
combined fieldwork drawn upon work in
the area of phenomenology and media
making to explore infrastructural sights
or prophecies that are invisible you
might
say culturally unintelligible as opposed
and literally invisible yet are integral
to media cultures and media economics
and industries and to to use those that
fieldwork as a way of also trying to
formulate critical languages and for
making these sites intelligible so that
in media studies not all of our work is
about looking at content on screens or
analyzing narrative structure but
actually thinking about how signals move
invisibly and imperceptibly to
throughout different parts of the world
and some of this work has also been
about studying peripheries within the
global media economy rather than the
sites such as Hollywood or Bollywood or
Nollywood to think really about various
sites so I'll just give you a sense of
some of these sites I'm interested in
for example thinking about what it means
in the context of the war in the former
Yugoslavia to ruin a socialist
telecommunication system and bring it
literally to the ground I have tried to
think about the physical arrangement of
socio-technical relations of mobile
telephony infrastructure in Mongolia and
how there's a completely resourceful and
innovative way in which walking phone
workers actually moved help to move
signals throughout ulaanbataar I've also
been interested in the work of
electrical linemen
I think electrical line men and women
are undergirding our global media
economy and I've worked a little bit
with this artist Michael Parker who has
done studies in the training grounds of
these linemen to try to make visible
their label labor in maintaining
repairing and sustaining the operation
of power grids that are integral to the
global and media global media and
digital economy and then in the last few
years I've been working in rural Zambia
with some computer scientists and local
communities in maccha
to try to understand how when we talk
about the global digital economy and
Internet infrastructure often water gets
kind of overlooked as completely
essential to thinking about global
digitization in these areas there would
there could be no internet users without
women water carriers and who carry water
to keep people alive so that they could
use cell phones and the Internet so I
try to also think about these systems
relationally as well and then just a
couple more examples and then we'll move
on one of my grad students at UC Santa
Barbara was doing work with migrant farm
workers and digital radio in Oxnard
California so thinking about how signals
are moving across farm fields where
strawberries are being picked and
signals are being broadcast in mixed
echo and Zapotec indigenous languages
that are largely unspoken and unheard in
many parts of California even though
people migrate from Oaxaca Mexico and
speak only those languages and then
finally I've also been trying to think
about the grounded dimensions of drone
warfare to not only think about you know
drone war from the perspective of the
remote cockpit pilot sensor interfaces
but like what's happening on the ground
and that's part of a broader part of
this work when I do this work I try to
think about it as footprint analysis and
I start with maps of coverage zones of
electronic coverage zones or networks
and then I literally walk through those
areas in an effort to combine
cartography with site based fieldwork
and geo annotation I'm in the process
some of this work is laid out in this
book that I recently published with my
former PhD student Nicole Starr Celski
called signal traffic and then I'm
trying to develop a lab here I'm in the
process of developing a lab within
comparative Media Studies and writing
called global media technologies and
cultures lab so the kinds of images that
I've shown you very quickly here and the
kinds of images we've seen in some of
Trevor's previous work which I know many
of you are very familiar with involved
prefer carrying or moving camera
equipment to particular sites and then
framing objects or fields of view in an
effort to make invisible things visible
and so this product this practice
involved a human camera operator and
assumed the reader of the images would
be a human what's really interesting and
exciting about Trevor's current work and
his new work is that he's trying to get
us to think about what happens when you
know humans are removed from the
equation of image production and
consumption or at least he's you know
what we can get into this little bit
more but so what we're going to talk
about today and what I'm going to ask
him to talk about right now to get us
into this discussion is what trevor is
calling invisible images which are
becoming increasingly ubiquitous and
kind of signal a major shift he's
arguing in our visual culture so we're
going to shift now to the other slide
and then I'm going to ask Trevor to get
started with a question and maybe while
we're switching over I could just start
off Trevor by asking you with a quite
general question you argued in a
provocative piece and new inquiry
recently that during the last decade
visual culture quote has become detached
from human eyes and largely become
invisible maybe you could tell us what
you mean by that I'm like what you're I
think we definitely both have a shared
interest in infrastructures and signals
moving through infrastructures and you
know what the consequences of that are
and I think was one of the to me one of
the most dramatic things that has kind
of had yeah but also I my background the
artist so I'm interested in not only how
images function in the world but how we
read them like what are these very
strange things that we call images and I
would sort of submit that over the last
really about 10 years or so that we've
seen the emergence of a very different
kind of images that have come online and
these are images that machines make in
order to be able to communicate with
other machines right and there's lots of
examples of that use a very basic
example would be like um like a
self-driving car have to move around the
city it has to kind of collect some kind
of information about that city turn it
into something that I can use but it's
like really an image system an imaging
system that is made for like one kind of
machining system for a different
machining system to do something with
and it's completely invisible the kind
of image that we see here on the left
that's made for humans to be able to
diagnose how that machine vision systems
working that's for us that's why it
doesn't need to aberrated
however the the stuff that the images
that it makes for itself are are the
same stuff that any other digital image
is made out of it's just not rendered
into a human form there's many many
different kinds of examples of this you
can go with facial recognition in cities
and airports and smartphones and
shopping centers you can talk about
computer vision systems used in supply
chains manufacturing quality control and
we're talking observe invitin yesterday
about they're using agriculture and this
also extends to domains of image making
that I think we would normally think of
as being human to human like in social
media for example like I might share
something on social media with you and
we look at it we share like oh that's a
cute picture whether it would have you
and the metaphor that we have for that
exchange would be like a photo album or
sharing photos where it feels like oh
I'm showing you this photograph and that
that's corporeally that's what it feels
like what's going on but in the
background that's not at all what's
going on you're feeding it to your
feeding it to a database of sorts and
that image is being continually mined by
very powerful algorithms and artificial
neural networks convolutional neural
networks they're trying to extract
metadata from that about us about our
relationship about what kind of objects
are in those images who is in those
images what can we learn from you know
from those sorts of things and so I
think that all of this adds up to a
world in which actually most of the
images made in the world right now are
made by machines for other machines and
they see in profoundly different
we do or see what have you and in that
old model of humans
you know seeing an image and
interpreting it and reading it like
basically the whole entire field of like
visual studies and much of like literary
criticism in these kinds of fields has
to be modified to think about what how
these non-human imaging systems not only
see but do work in the world and so I
think the project I've been working on
for a number of years and this is
actually the first time I remember
talking about that publicly other than
that article I wrote is being to try to
first of all figure out what is the
formal aspect of these in other words
like what actually are images that are
made by machines for other machines and
then what are how do they operate
differently than the way that images
made by humans for other humans operate
can you talk a little bit about the
material processes kind of on the back
end of the generation of these images
and maybe walk us through some specific
examples so we get a sense of the the
work that you've done to try to render
this intelligible to us yeah so that I
mean over the years we're just using you
know if we're not doing original
research I run our art studio it's not
scholarship whatever we're just
basically finding some off-the-shelf
tools as well developing our own tools
in the studio that allows us to do like
what that image of the self-driving car
was doing to implement a computer vision
system and then draw stuff for us that
tries to show us as a human what a
particular system is looking at these
are some examples of that some of the
computer vision systems are very simple
just looking for edges lines
relationships between one image and the
next
purely kind of formal operations and
then image like this kind of speaks to
that this is a you know the series of
algorithms are overlaid on the
photograph but that we get further and
further into this world and this is a
kind of a representation of image that a
facial recognition system would use it's
a kind of image that would where if I
want to recognize your face I want to
just basically figure out what the
figure print of your face is what's the
difference between your face and
everybody else's face in the world
what I want to know and that that kind
of produces images like this in some
instances though is that like an
approximation of a digital approximation
of someone's face based on a machine
looking at multiple images of that face
yeah exactly exactly
and that and that's what this kind of
images as well and we don't really have
vocabularies for these kinds of images
so that's been a kind of another part of
the project is sort of like inventing
language within the studio just so we
can talk to each other about what some
of these things are um this is a kind of
image that we're calling a linear
classifier and that's a real word and
this is kind of a quick and dirty way to
do to do object recognition and what you
do in this technique is you might take
like a million images and those million
images are organized into a thousand
classes of different objects right so
you would say oranges and apples and
grapefruits in the Sun and basketballs
or what-have-you and then you write a
very simple thing that you can do is
create an image that is almost like a
template for what all of those different
classes should look like in other words
an image that represents statistically
what what an image of a given object is
most likely to look like so for example
this would be a candle this is a rose
this is a shark and what what this
technique is doing is just going through
every pixel of every image of a shark
and saying like this pixel is probably
going to be some version of gray in the
middle so that's probably where the
shark is like an image of pixel on the
outside of it's probably going to seem
to be some kind of blue because the
sharks probably in the ocean so again
before you ask just so we also
understand and so could these images if
there was such a thing as a visual
search engine could that be put in it as
an input and then presumably you would
have a bunch of images of sharks return
well that's that's the next step that
we're doing so this is a much cruder way
to do that and what you're talking about
doing is actually um some work that
we're just getting to be able to work
now which is using neural networks and
sort of the the more advanced way of
doing like um these object recognition
stuff is you train a neural network
see things and so we've been training
our own networks and then what we do
what we can do is say okay artificial
intelligence you have learned how to
recognize what a shark is now draw me a
picture of a shark and these are the
kinds of images that you get back when
you do that we basically say evolve this
image into your 99% confident that it's
a shark and then show me what you've got
and it's different every time that we do
that which is really kind of interesting
so there's this kind of thing and then
we're doing even weirder stuff where
we're saying evolve me an image like our
neural network evolved me an image of
what's happening at a particular neuron
and what's normally like a hidden layer
of that so show me an image of something
that you've invented to try to recognize
other kinds of objects and you get these
weird almost like photorealistic of
things that like don't exist that the
neural network kind of made up so the
machine vision then in some sense has a
extends re-educate us about how we might
see exactly like the formal qualities of
it are just really different than the
way that humans work and I get in big
fights about you know of computer vision
scientists about this because they would
insist like but no human see with edges
I'm like see with edges that has like
almost nothing to do with it like but um
anyway you can have those kind of
conversations but I think the other part
of the the project though is really
thinking about the consequences of that
you know and and this is kind of a joke
kind of I'm just showing you stuff from
like my sketchbooks basically from this
project I mean this is kind of a funny
image you know it says it's like a
neural network saying like this is
definitely a red and greeting Apple
right um and this is I think this is
kind of funny but this to me is a very
scary image actor this image actually
terrifies me
and and for a lot of different reasons
because I think when you're talking
about the deployment of automated vision
or autonomous vision and it vision is
probably even the wrong where you should
probably be just saying sensing that's
another thing that there are kind of we
have corporeal analogy that we use
though there's a difference in hearing
seeing this and that that don't really
apply we start getting into this world
as well
but again thinking about consequences
like none of these things are either
built or deployed in a vacuum right and
they're always designed to serve
particular kinds of interests and those
interests in our society tend to be
either money-making or law enforcement
flash state power right those are the
big things that drive much of this work
and you can do all kinds of enormous ly
powerful things with systems like this
so for example there's Ben for the town
in Texas there was a company called
vigilant solutions what was doing was
going around with cameras mounted on the
backs of police cars and on their own
cars and all was doing was reading the
license plates of cars so collects these
huge databases of where cars are one of
the projects they did a few years ago is
make a partnership with a county in
Texas and they said okay we have our
huge database of license plates we have
our cameras that can read license plates
why don't we put our cameras on the
backs of all your police cars for free
and you're going to attach our cameras
to your databases of people who have you
know outstanding arrest warrants or
tickets or whatever and then when as the
cop drives around town they'll
automatically get pinged if our camera
sees a car that has a fine or a warrant
or something that associated with it and
the top has a credit card reader and
pull that person over and say you have
this outstanding where you can pay it
right now with a credit card and it goes
away and digital installation says we
get 25 bucks service fee every time that
happens right municipality loves it
because it's a way for them to generate
money very easily company loves it it's
free money for them too but what that
ends up win very quickly is a situation
like Ferguson we have these incredibly
predatory municipal structures rights
that are disproportionately obviously
gonna affect people who are under
surveillance or having times with a lot
and haven't been able to kind of take
care of that so that's just one but
there's many many many of these
different kinds of consequences from the
kind of Practical so things that are a
little bit more philosophical and that's
why this one scares me so much which is
that I think that when we're talking
about progress of the a certain of
Rights or self-determination feel like
social struggles are always struggles
over meaning right so when we think
about you know histories of civil rights
or feminism or think that most of us
would agree are good things like a huge
part of those projects was to try to
rename things right took a different
kinds of associations that not come up a
number of times there's that how how
that francha bility of meaning is
actually a really important means by
which we exercise power and
determination and and that's why this
scares me so much because so is your
concern and your fear around this image
related to the idea that the image is
now produced in a way that its
interpretation is always already encoded
in it and that it's already been machine
read and possibly acted upon before the
human eye has a chance to even begin to
make sense of it is that what you're
getting at it's about it but it's also
part of an automated system right so for
example you'd like with the license why
trading things it is a very obvious
example like no this is a license plate
and it has this weren't attached to it
and that triggers this state
intervention into somebody's life right
but there's not there's no way to
contest that operation um not not that
event ways to contest it either away but
learn ting it solidifies our
relationships that already exist so I
mean I'm just thinking about
historically there have been all kinds
of you know surveillance systems put
into place and images collected whether
photographically or cinematically on so
what is it really about this new shift
in visual culture that you're trying to
explore in this machine vision work that
is different is it about processing
power of the image than the logistics of
its networking the ease of acting upon
images efficiently as machines read them
I'm trying to kind of get you to talk a
little bit more about what is that what
is the paradigmatic shift that these
technological transformations facilitate
in terms of a broader I mean I think the
paradigmatic transformation is the fact
that you that you don't need the human
anymore right and that you can operate
at scale right you can like literally
perform operations on trillions of
images right which is something that
just humans cannot do right and that you
can there and because you can do that
you can set up enforcement mechanisms
for whatever you want at NASA scales
okay right so you can easily imagine
like a smart sentencing city that can
enforce all jaywalking that can enforce
all even though every need every car
that that exceeds the speed limit every
car that takes a right on a red turn
what you can you know treat these
incredibly efficient mechanisms of
enforcing whatever rules that you want
to enforce whether those are the state
rules or or rules having to do with
insurance or granted or that sort of
thing and I and I and I am concerned
that that comes at the expense of
Liberty did you want to talk about that
well I mean this is another example of
that I mean this is like so for example
there you if you're writing have
software that detects gender you can be
male or female I don't like in the
software and like what I'm saying is
like that gender something that's very
much be contested right now like we
don't want to think about genders as
being like this binder istic kind of
thing and so I mean for me this kind of
image is again showing that enforcement
mechanism in place so you were saying
earlier you felt like theory current
theories of representation are
insufficient for allowing us to
understand the kind of lexicon of
machine vision and what its implications
might be you know after as an extension
of theories of representation we've had
a lot of work on effect and imaging and
then there seems to be a new turn also
in terms of logistical media or what
Harun Farooqi called the operational
image so do you see this work that
you're doing now is
really kind of delving deeper into that
those kinds of absolute understandings
of the visual and the power absolutely
yeah absolutely I think it's very much a
kind of extension of the work that
Haruki did on on operational images
Peter Galison has done some work on this
question as well as kind of picking up
on but the harbor okie that did that in
hue did I machine and some articles he
was writing about this in the in the
early 2000s and it was sort of he was
kind of looking at he's like oh yeah
that's kind of weird these other kinds
of images that sort of do emergent and I
think like between then and now that
actually becomes the dominant form of
image making like in the world and sorry
I do think that there's um he definitely
noticed that there's this thing what's
happening you know but it's just
exploded too thin but largely and
visibly right so after looking at a lot
of this work like how do machines look
how can you as a human described how a
machine looks or how it reads how it
senses like its senses according to the
forms of power that have been coded into
it mm-hmm and so who's doing that well
you pick your who do you want like so
insurance companies are doing that well
you know law enforcement companies are
doing that um a Taser just bought a body
cam from for the interface or
recognition company right so the body so
we all kind of have this idea of cops
wear body cams and maybe they'll you
know police themselves a little bit more
we'll turn the body cam into an active
sensor right they can recognize
everybody this interval could they could
write a record of everybody right so I
mean there's there's all many many
different domains in which this happened
it's incredible how fast it's happening
- I remember in 1995 when this was
during the war in Yugoslavia when the
then Secretary of State Madeleine
Albright had released satellite images
of mass graves and Sarah Bonita and
these images were released six weeks
after satellites had acquired them and
so there was a lot of discussion about
the problematic delay in releasing these
image
to the world so that they might be used
as a means of policy formation and
possible intervention but now what
you're suggesting is that on computer
processing and image accumulation is
happening so quickly and these things
are so efficient now that one could
presumably see something instantly and
this is what we see with drone one I'm
in act interim in the in the image so
the image really becomes you know the
the theater of intervention of not
something to look at in a contemplative
gesture but a logistical field of
operation and so we need as scholars and
critics and artists and scientists to be
thinking I think about this shift and
what it means to not have the time to
sit back and interpret and analyze what
we were are seeing in a way that maybe
we had in the past where machines are
reading images for us and acting on them
before we even have the time to notice I
think that's a really important thing to
follow up on and intervene and we just
have about two minutes left do you have
any final things that you want to
mention before we you know you're about
it's it's I think that did I have to
come to think about it on two axes there
is this kind of horizontal axis of the
camera taking a picture doing something
with it whether that's shooting a
missile are issuing a drone strike or
affecting somebody's credit rating or
what-have-you but then also on a
historical axis because the other thing
that's that is kind of new is that the
constant accumulation of images right
they don't go away that can be
retroactive Lee mind right and so that
that's another dimension to this as well
and the part of that that I worry about
is to what extent do we become stuck in
time maybe because when you're when
you're having these very like if you're
creating a neural network or something
like that that's going to analyze a body
of data you have to give it images from
the past or data from the past and the
past is can be a bad place the past can
be patriarchal and racist and that sort
so when you're teaching you know these
kinds of systems with data from the past
you almost are you creating the
precondition that conditions through
which that past is continually
reproduced okay I think we'll we'll stop
there so that we can move on with the
other presentations but thank you very
much
[Applause]